so I have to start with the most
important question up front I know that
Zach watched a lot of Game of Thrones
and because he cast a lot of people from
Game of Thrones in this movie so really
I have to ask you how did you get cast
CU you were not in Game of
Thrones how did I get cast
well uh here we come to find out that
Zach has been working on this for you
know almost a centuries I mean but three
decades yes for three decades he's been
working on this and um and I come to get
a call about Rebel Moon and I'm talking
to him and I've come to find out that um
uh it seems like we've worked together
with you know uh before and when he was
still in film school I used to go to
that film School uh as a model you know
in my early days in uh in California as
a model to pose for those uh film you
know yeah film
students right and so fast forward to I
guess you know three decades later two
33 days later 33 yeah years later and
um here we are with Rebel Moon
individual question for both of you I
like throwing a curve at the beginning
also if I'm butchering all my questions
I'm gonna start with if someone has
never seen a Zack Snider movie take out
Rebel Moon because everyone's gonna
watch if someone's never seen a Zack
Snider movie what's the one you think
they should start with uh well I I would
always go to uh 30000 yeah I think so
too I was always going through 300 300
really mocked me uh as an audience and
as also as an actor
um he was uh the tremendous um creative
uh input in that
film uh really I mean he SP spoke volume
to a lot of people in the world right um
had a such an impact yeah and so that
would be uh the one yeah the one I would
uh would pick I'd have to second that
and just I just remember he finds such a
beautiful balance of beauty and
brutality it's just like what a I can't
swear can I you you can actually
cool thing to achieve you know what I
mean and also like you look at 300 and
there's fast Bender there's Butler
there's all these you know a lot of time
with action movies you know we we back
in the day we wouldn't cast dramatic
actors or stuff like that and it's
wonderful to see a world where all these
genres are colliding where where act you
know dramatic actors are taking their
shot at action and also he was one of
the first people I remember being like
okay he really takes physical aesthetic
seriously like you know that's a real
big part of his ethos and creating these
Warriors we're not we're not CG eying
this stuff you're going to emulate that
by personifying that physically and I
think that that's why I really love 300
jumping into Rebel Moon so uh I am
curious what is something in part one
that you cannot wait for audiences to
see and what is something in part two
you can't wait for audiences to
see part one uh I just I I think I think
velt is so I it's it's it features
potentially even more in part two but I
think velt is such a physical feat to to
have achieved you know just for context
you know it's 3 to five acres of really
built Village uh river that was been
man-made by sack mined into the desert I
mean it's just it reminds me of those
big sets of all of the Rings and all
that stuff and I just it just that is
just it's such a beautiful thing to fall
in love with the the romance the romance
of it and for the second movie it's it's
our Back stories I think that's not
second move part two of movie One
technically it's our Back stories it's
an opportunity to really delve into the
individual the characters how they
intersect why they're really here and
you know it's it's uh you really get to
a bit more of a an over ending kind of
feeling for every all of the The Misfits
I
conquer is there anything that for real
is there anything that you in both films
part
two uh has more to offer I think uh
especially uh about
you know each of our characters and how
we uh you know come together you know
against um you know various U you know
obstacles obstacles and challenges um
and uh how do we all evolve out of that
and so I think part two is U and part
two also I mean this is the
genie um from Zach the fact that that he
cast a it's no surprise that he went you
know almost
globally uh during his cast you know of
course stars is uh you know have Russian
and um uh Indian I you know of course
originally from West Africa uh
and literally the way he wrote the story
I could feel the uh you know of course
the geopolitical tentacles of Africa you
know that been holding the continent of
Africa back for centuries I could feel
that coming off the page like literally
I feel like this he's telling my
story you see sure so and that said also
the fact that I was cast and part of the
requirements for was for me to sing uh
you know but I'll just leave it at that
yeah yeah yeah wait just wait to see
this yeah part two is more characters
more war it's it's it's beautiful it's
it's the culmination cuz that's that's
what we're seeing and we're watching a
the rise right so with making this film
uh you shot for like 153 days it was
like a marathon was 153 days so was it
153 days yeah we CT out at about 140 130
you and I but yeah so my thing is was
there a night the night before filming
that you're actually like a little bit
nervous like you're in your head a
little bit thinking how are we going to
do this tomorrow certainly that for me
uh the first day was like that the first
day of filming and which was the first
still filming for the entire film yeah
he he he opened us up so
uh we did that shot that was that first
day of filming and for me it was uh
also uh where I get discovered by the
group sure
poock that
scene
um felt very uh
greedy
and it almost like a um a throwback for
you know my glad of day sure must been
kind of like not dissociating but kind
of bizarre right for myself
um yeah I mean for starters you know I'm
as much as I've been a working actor for
a while you know it's very different
sharing a screen with jimond and Charlie
and then and Sophia and nille and Ed and
Anthony bloody Hopkins you know it's
just it's a whole it's I think if if I
started looking at it as a whole it
would overwhelm me and what I just did
is I just focused on what I knew which
was the character what I understood and
I and tried my best to trust the work i'
been doing and and and it paid off I
believe but um you know what really made
that easier and put those nerves aside
you just the humility of all all these
actors it was really eclectic bunch of
people different energy levels different
types of people but we came together and
and it and it
you know all of that can of fell to the
Wayside we just became peers and we just
became brothers and comrades in against
a you know against the tough 150-day
slug on that note I really do hope it's
a huge hit for you guys and I'm looking
forward to part
two